Holle with single Moms Club where the
kamacho is drew barrymore we are with
both in New York today and we wanted to
know what advice Gwyneth had for all the
single moms out there like Drew and the
way cover slit people are loving you
know that you guys are able to so
co-parent and be a family and vacation
as a family so what's some advice that
you have especially for your close
girlfriend's going through something
similar like that in their lives you
know it's really kind of just an
exercise in letting go and forgiving and
embracing what's wonderful about the
person and what you fell in love with in
the first place and you know it is
possible to sort of separate out the
romantic part and still forge that
wonderful familial relationship with
somebody when it knows what it's like to
be a single mom it's been over two years
it's her conscious uncoupling from
Coldplay's Chris Martin we love that she
shared her recent vacay pics with kids
Apple and Moses with the world and now
the lifestyle guru is sharing what she
feeds them in her new cookbook it's all
easy you sit at Moses and Apple this
book is for you and you've said it's
been a complete nightmare keeping them
away from processed food at home I have
certain tricks like I really find that
if I put out lots of dipping sauces or
like there's a lettuce cup and they're
filling things themselves or they'll eat
more vegetables if there's like all
these different sauces to try like pesto
and hummus and miso dressing or whatever
my kids are pretty good I mean at home I
try to keep the pantry pretty clean but
you know when we're out in the world
it's all Oreos and you know cheez-its
and stuff like that unfortunately well
we're all relieved because we're too
fond of Oreos and cheez-its as well as
healthy food a lot of people were
surprised to see that you've not own a
microwave I do not own a microwave no I
believe in old-fashioned ways of heating
things up you have some Nevers in this
cookbook which I love now never grabbed
a to-go salad well my philosophy is it's
really easy to make your own salad at
home it's cheaper it's healthier you
know what's in it I've had some great
experiences with the grab-and-go salad
really really terrible one what is your
favorite beauty flute something that you
know is gonna make you look good um you
know I think a really nutrient dense
greens juice always makes your skin glow
least favorite food um I really don't
like dill it's not technically a food
but it really offends me if there was
one food that you could eat for the rest
of your life what would it be
Pizza if it wasn't bad for you healthy
pizza you can create one of those I mean
just real pizza would be mine probably
number one one of his good friends with
drew Barrymore who is now having to
learn how to co-parent she and will
Kopelman's daughter's three-year-old
olive and Frankie who was almost two are
her everything